and the Oscar goes to
the Oscar goes to Eminem Jeff bass and
Luis Resto for Lose Yourself from eight
miles
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the first Academy Award and
first nomination for Eminem Jeff bass
and Luis Resto
[Music]
oh my
this all goes to Marshall
um I'm privileged grateful
to be involved with this song along with
my co-writers and Friends Jeff bass
Marshall Mathers who couldn't be here
it's a great thing working with Marshall
day in day out he's creative
he has symphonies in his head that I'm
privileged to put on the tape
he's a good man good heart
Here's to You Marshall thank you so much
I love you Colleen Kyle Olivia everybody
thank you